[Music]
hello everybody my name is Vitaly namer
and I am the Grand Master resident here
at the st. Louis chess club today we
have a lesson about play like a pro but
pretty much all the lessons that you get
here is about play like a pro you know
so anyway so today player in in play
like a pro I like to show some of some
of my games some of my ideas and then
we're gonna jump into some some other
subjects as well so basically here I
decide what what to coaching what what
to show you today I wanted to show you
one of my games that I have played a
long time ago about five years ago
against a very strong young master you a
u.s. Grandmaster his name is Mackenzie
Muller goes by the name Mac molar as
well this was a norm tournament back
then so that that win was pretty
important for me and I was playing with
the with the black pieces so Mac molar
versus white alley name let's look what
happened Evo was played in the in the
first on the first move it did not
surprise me because I have prepared for
this game now usually I'm a c5 player I
really like this at Cillian I'm very
sharp player like sharper positions but
I have prepared something very special
for Mac in this in this game and I
decided to surprise him with E 5 so ii 5
is is what I have played we have seen by
the way in the candidates tournament
which is going on right now
that II five and C 5 are the most
popular choices today so there is a
reason for that by the way so if I was
played 9 of 3 a white best move in the
position there is no doubt about that
96 blacks best move in
no doubt about that and usually if you
look at the database Bishop to b5 will
be the most popular and famous move
which is going into the Ray Lopez or
some people like to call it rui the
spanish defense there should be five but
nowadays we have another very
fashionable move which is Bishop to c4
this is the the start of the gold copy
on Oh Italian defense or go copy
pianissimo
by the way peony piano pianissimo
somebody told me it's a it's a soft and
softer quiet yes quite and quieter quite
game not not so quiet though as you'll
see from the game so Bishop c4 was
played by by Mac and here black has two
main responses they are Bishop to c5 and
Knight to f6 and in my professional
opinion both of those moves are pretty
good a pretty standard is just each one
of those moves has its advantages and
disadvantages just to show you what of
the advantages and disadvantages of each
move for example Knight f6 now 9 f6 will
will attack this pawn on e4 and it will
force white probably to play something
like either d3 to defend this pawn on e4
or a wife can also go to Knight to g5
this is what we call the two or the
three Knights defense some people like
to call it the fried liver although it's
not Friday yet not fried liver yet in
this position we know that black needs
to play this move d5 now another move
which can be played in this position y
can also play this move Knight to c3
this is just a developing move
defending the pawn however it almost
looks like the full night's defense
almost looks like the phone is defense
but the bishop on the phone eyes defense
is placed here on b5 there is a slight
difference between the phone eyes
defense and what we got in this position
so let's see if you can figure out
what's the difference what what can
black play here which will at least
equalize his position and that is
correct you are too fast so Knight takes
on e4 we have this small tactic in this
position and the reason why it works is
because if the knight takes he only for
now we have this move d5 d5 forking the
knight and the bishop well it's not
losing for white it's not life
threatening fall out of a white but he
probably might give away give up his
bishop play something like d3 to defend
the knight and in this position really
black has no trouble black is the one
who is controlling more space as we
heard from from Sam's lecture today and
the pawns you know I have this nice pawn
on e5 which is more advanced it is
giving me more space in the center as
well as the queen is on d5 usually we
don't like our Queen to be placed in the
center of the board but in this case you
know nobody we can really attack the
Queen out of there and so really this
position is considered at least at least
an equal position for black so this is
the biggest difference now just to if
you are asking yourself or wait a second
if I took here on e4 can't white play
this intermediate move Bishop takes f7
check and the question and the answer is
yes you can and you should maybe but in
this case we can just capture the bishop
and white will take our knight on e4 so
now you're going to ask yourself oh wait
a second didn't I just lose the castle
is it my king here on f7 is so we
what did what did we gain so what would
be black's best response in this
position think about it
that is correct you guys are rocking
running today
good job d5 that is the best move the
black can do because again we control
the center now why can either go forward
or go backwards if we try to check out
King on f7 the King can go probably to
g8 I would say or even even he it would
be okay but I like to to hide my King
here on g8 which is fine and for example
if white castles we can then kick the
night out with h6 neither day we can for
example we can just take on h3
and I think that probably our King is
even safer than this King on g1 so this
is just just an illustration to what
could have happened at the end so in
this position is of playing Knight f6 I
decided to play Bishop to c5 that's the
other good move for black now Bishop c5
the advantages of Bishop c5 is that it
does not allow y to play Knight g5 now
and go into the fried liver because the
queen is going to take this night on on
g5 the Napali odo is not attacked only
for so now White has some extra options
what can play for example c3 and go to
the Italian defence they go echo piano
and after Knight of 6 d4 so that's
that's that's possible so that was not
available when we played Knight of 6
because white is have just taken on e4
simply after a city-wide can also try to
play this move B for this is what we
call the the Evans gambit Bishop takes
before for example so and then white
will play c3 we sacrifice a pawn to get
another temple as white and the white
pushes d4 this did not happen in the
game in the game Mac just canceled
so far so good well 9 of 6 was played in
the game that's what I played that was
pretty much population so far not that a
lot of population but at this moment why
it can probably have students supposed
to to play DT here to defend the spawn
95 will not be so threatening to meet
them to me right now because I can just
castle so I don't see the point of play
95 now but my opponent really liked to
play this system D for sacrificing
sacrificing upon so the question is here
in this position how do we react to such
a move no do we panic do we not panic
hopefully we don't we don't panic so
what would heal with the world do we
retreat with the bishop do we take the
pawn if we take the pawn which piece has
to take the pawn lots of decisions need
needs to be made made in this position
so think about it think about what is
the best solution for black here and if
anybody knows what is the name of this
variation ok so we have somebody said 94
ok let's try to hear everybody today so
think about this okay so we have 19 c4e
takes d4 mm-hmm tonight takes he takes
and the other options
d 5 pretty brave yeah well nobody wants
to go back with the bishop that's a good
sign so let's look at those at least
those moves that we have just this
discussed let's start with the D 5 Wow
BAM counter-attack on us in a Saturn now
I remember my coaches always used to
tell me that when we play with black
pieces first of all we need to equalize
the position we can't just go on an
attack and attack White's pieces so lots
of people make this mistake as you can
see we immediately put play d5 we say
okay we don't care you're attacking me
I'm going to attack your back but with
black it's a very bad idea usually in
most cases because my King is still here
now if it was would be already canceled
that could be an interesting choice
however right now immediately after
playing d5 I'm asking myself well why
the second if the pawn just takes on d5
how am I going to defend my Bishop on c5
and my knight on c6 it's pretty much
almost impossible Knight takes on d4
Knight takes that's interesting and then
maybe 90 X 25
taking on d5 would be extremely
dangerous I wonder why I feel there's
some kind of a tactic coming either
night of seven or maybe just see three I
just play see three just ask you okay
well you'll move your night efore okay
more counter-attack interesting I'm
gonna take I want to take everything I'm
gonna take here I'm gonna take here
gonna be a bloodshed over here
okay so d5 I think is just too much too
much I'm gonna get a heart attack
okay let's try to take with a pawn first
with the pawn I think this is also
possible however I have a White has this
move e5 and there is such evaluation
then black can play d5 for example here
that's a different story there's a
different counter-attack and they
usually take here you take the bishop so
there is such a variation that's if we
play with a pawn now 1974 that's a
different story because on Knight X on
d4 you can take on e5 and I think that
we might get in trouble with this
Buddhist pawn here on f7 if I'm not
mistaken and he castles maybe maybe this
Bishop is going to get into trouble
maybe I can play something like before
Oh
93 or baby [ __ ] Bishop g5 would be
pretty strong at Bishop e7 so I don't do
not like it as much
well there's another move that we
haven't considered and this is simply by
capturing here on d4 because essentially
when white is playing this move on to d4
this square is defendant only two times
and it's attacked three times by the
Bishop Knight endpoint so it's supposed
to lose a pawn Dwight so after d4
I just kept it to the bishop and I'm
here to say well prove proved to me that
there is some kind of a compensation for
white for this pawn so this is just one
of the lines and this is still too early
why it takes you on d4 again I would
like to take with the knight now why is
that well if I take the pawn white we'll
have the chance to play e5 and again
some some tactical maneuvers here on the
e-file so 9 x d4 so far so good
and now what is playing this stronghold
f4 suddenly all the attack is coming
coming at us so this is gonna be a good
a good lesson about defense probably
talks about defense everybody was just
to attack okay so what do we do here
what's my next move how do we defend
yeah just the six very good don't don't
panic d6f takes e5 D takes d5 Bishop
takes Bishop to g5 so this is the main
premise fall for white in sacrificing
the pawn in this variation which by the
name I still don't know the name
if anybody can google that so the bishop
comes here to g5 white got to bishops he
got this open file the F file and really
black has a choice to make I mean what
what do I do
almost looks like I have no no moves so
let's see what what do you guys can come
up with so black to move somebody
surprise you in the opening who pretty
much played them all one of the more
most forest variations so what to do
Queen e2 Queen d7 okay interesting idea
Queen d7 okay I like it as well that's
okay
similar ideas somebody wants to Castle
Queen's a queen side obviously if black
tries to Castle short side then some bad
things will happen I'm not exactly sure
what but just looking at this position
take take and somehow queen h5 and then
the this night is gonna come in to c3
oops 2 C 3 D 5 Knight of 6 and looks
looks pretty scary for for black so I'm
glad that nobody said short castle so
queen is 726 anybody else's any other
other ideas rook g8 okay interesting so
the first thing I would like to ask
myself by the way is what is the current
whites threat does he have a threat
that's if it was white yeah c3 so white
wants to play c3 once we move out all
night he's going to take our Queen
exchange the Queen's on d8 was the
Queen's on exchange he can simply take
one of six gain the pawn back leave us
with other castle and probably with this
witness one of seven and and on e5 maybe
so that's the problem
so let's look now at the suggested move
moves that well suggested hero g8 27:26
now there's really only one move that
takes out Queen out of the D file and
this is Queen e7 and this is what I
played in the game so just to illustrate
a queen d6 I think probably just c3 I
have to move the night somewhere let's
try Knight
see six I guess take take take take rook
takes f6 and not the end of the world
but I'm going to lose another pawn and
it's gonna be tough to defend you g8
similar ideas happening so I played
Queen to e7 so as I said I've never
played this move this this position
before I always play Sicilian and ever
play d5 so therefore this was part of my
population Queen e7 and now white needs
to make a choice well what do I do next
if white plays for example 93 with the
idea to play 95 we can simply play
Bishop e6 for example in this position
and it's totally fine I just want to
catch along if white plays c3 now the
knight can simply go to e 6 and knowing
this Bishop on on g5 and he probably
needs to take a knight otherwise if it
doesn't then my position is fine so take
take and that the night goes 2 to 4 and
together with the rook g8 I might have
some very very strong attack myself so
City that does not scare me so much what
else can it can he do there's some of
the king h1 but then basically my idea
is to play Bishop e6 or Bishop d7 and
long castle yes so what was played in
the game is this move Knight to 83 in a
very sneaky move why it is waiting to
see what are we going to do he kind of
makes a connection between between the
rooks what's the develop the stroke on
a1 at some point he also preparing the
real goal of this move Knight a3 is that
white really wants to bring the Knight
to d5 or
f5 but as we have seen that if the
knight goes to c3 I can just defend you
know that with the bishop on e6 and then
the problem for him if he brings the
knight on c3 he
cannot kick my night from the fallout
and so the idea of Nigeria is to play
what's Italy then night to see - and
then 93 that's a very very sneaky idea
okay
so black to move
what should I do against this plan after
the play here
there should be six is possible yeah
let's look at those two moves that will
suggest that Queen c5 immediately we see
the threat right queen coming up coming
up here next to the king although even
if it was black to move here I'm not
sure how we could use it immediately
maybe to take this bishop but you know
simply I think while just breaking h1
and the question is okay the Queen
position position on on c5 is very well
but what to do next I mean also the
Queen was defending an item of six and
so how are we going to defend a knight
now so this is I think that you know
they're the weakness of 25 now another
move was suggested Bishop three six now
Bishop e6 let's look we're here what if
white plays c3 here like I can't quite
figure out what to do next with black so
because if we take this bishop on c4
first I wonder if act you can sacrifice
them on this but this will just help his
knight to come to e3 and then to a5 if
we try to move back with a knight to c6
that's a different story
I think that here again white would
probably play King h1
and black we have to find a way for his
next to move room theater I don't want
to play right because of Queen e2 or
something Queen b3 and now I cannot cast
alongside so the next move if you cannot
find the next move
don't feel bad because I did not find it
myself it was a population was an engine
move right sometimes we see this those
those engine moves but the idea here and
this in this position so this the bishop
is here the idea here is to make a
prophylactic a move and we already had a
few lessons about prophylaxis
prophylaxis was a term which was quoted
by Arab nimzowitsch and basically it
says try to prevent well at least
prepare for your opponent's plan in
addition I selected this this game
because just in last week we had I
showed another game game of mine which I
used similar trick and the same today in
his discussion about pawn structures he
he also mentioned this this amazing game
which was played by kramnik versus
Aronian and the move that was played
that amazes amazed everybody was rogue
g8 damn Saru g8 was played very very
strange move but very unequal yeah yeah
so but it's so in this moment so why do
place the rookie on g8 so first of all I
said to myself we don't want to castle
anymore
okay the castle is just too dangerous
and the second thing that we say to
ourselves okay at some point he will
capture this knight on f6 this this file
will be opened up one way or another so
route jet is simply a preparation move
we just prepare ourselves and put a rope
here you know in front of the king
exactly yeah so if you take my night
then you'll have to deal with my rock
okay so Ruby it was played and white
played came to h1 pretty much similar to
what was played in that game and what we
looked at today King left the G file as
well as also leaving this diagonal or
very important for white so it's a nice
nice defensive move in this case again I
had to figure out how to play the best
move for black here was actually just
playing this move Bishop d7 just
preparing long castle I was a little bit
more impatient and I decided okay let's
figure out what this Bishop is going to
do and I played h6 still a good move
obviously the bishop took on on f6 if it
doesn't take enough sticks I think that
even g5 is possible and then if it goes
there poverty like Bishop g4 and then H
5 H 4 just looks awful for white so at
least white gets to damage my pawn
structure Bishop takes on f6 pawn takes
on f6
c3 Knight a6
and night - see - okay still the
position is not so easy
yes I got my rook to the G file got rid
of this annoying pin but I'm stuck with
those with those very weak points I was
stuck with my King here on the 8th my
bishop hears he's not feeling so well
feeling sick at home tired so what to do
next like to move neither four is
possible yeah just me tonight baby
there should be seven you know okay rule
again I would like to so what 186 okay
so again I would like to focus on the
fact that in chess we have to figure out
what some opponents plan we cannot play
alone this game so what is White's plan
yeah 93 and the night is coming so okay
so now we know White's plan so for
everybody who is giving us an option a
six Bishop d7 and 94 I will play Knight
e3 and then what will be your next move
because if the knight gets there on to
f5 or d5 that's going to be pretty
devastating so I would be the second
move then hear me do you think yeah so
that's that's correct so that's what I
play in a game I have to prepare against
at night 93
correct anybody has any questions
anybody wants to look at the other moves
did you mention before neither for looks
very attractive super attractive I gotta
say
but after 93 the problem is that the
night defense on g2 as well and wants to
jump in now he cannot jump on d5 yet but
the problem is that GT is coming oh it
maybe can sacrifice on the rock on f4
and I don't really see away now I can
play c6 now but again the Bombers the g6
and ephah if I come back to his 6th and
9th 5 and you really don't want to let
this night come here to visit you so c6
is the the way I started my my defense
night to e3 and night to c5 I could have
done g5 I didn't like the fact that I'm
there kind of disturbing the dirac here
so played night to c5 now this square is
defended by the but a pawn this F v
square is defended by the bishop so far
I'm surviving that's that's a great
question in the game he played it just
to move after so if you play immediately
before I assume I can just take on e4
right there so he played Queen f3
so Queen f3 was played
not only the defending this but also
attacking the pollen of six yeah I have
no other move robbed you six so it's
easy to play when when there's only one
thought so Rho G six was played be for
modesty I don't have many options so
well Russia denied go
so I have I guess one two three four
okay so I held a six I held a for
anybody else yes so the night club got
to d7 on only six this seven just looks
that's just very bad
he thinks looks a little bit better but
after night coming to a five rook will
go to d1 and I don't see a way how can
we stop ninety-six and devastating
results so I had to choose between a 4
and a 6 now if I go to a six though
if it takes a night and I take again
looks pretty bad but this is just a pawn
structure I mean I have like one two
three four islands again the night the
rock will come here the night of time
here it's only gonna help him so I had
only one choice the power of elimination
yeah I mean it looks pretty bad on a4
right but on the other hand I move
forward and I take the pollen c3 and
okay that baby maybe can come back
through b6 so that's not much of a
choice rook a c1 was played because I
mean it's hard to white you tool to make
some some moves right because a if it
because Knight a5 all just exchange it
that's fine with me yes sure where can
you you will Jack would you like to
propose a mofo before white you're
saying that taking on c3 is probably
dangerous I go with you but me sure try
to make me
okay here would you three probably right
okay so here okay cantaloupe can I be
five because he's gonna take me and I'm
gonna lose this square what was it that
the principal that Sam had right I don't
want to give up my the attack on the on
the on this the defensible over the
square so okay let's go let's let's
think about go back
rook a d1 is this still about it not
even the main thinking I can just play
maybe like Bishop e6 all night night
even Knight b6 supposed to be fine
because I can just always take although
yeah if Knight b6 now we're gonna get to
this kind of variation and he can even
take on f7 so you almost got me but I'll
probably play Bishop e6 and I think I'm
supposed to be fine
so here I'm already two pawns up and who
knows maybe one day my king is gonna
find some cover over here after all
so after 94 was played white just play
bouquet c1 because why he wants to also
doesn't know what to do much he wants to
defend the pawn and he says okay well
what are you going to do next I mean
what is he King gonna go if I play
Bishop e6 for example then I was a bit
afraid that he's not played b5 I'm not
so sure why why I didn't choose Bishop
to d7 I think that if I play with Bishop
d7 now the idea of long casts so maybe I
was scared of Bishop to b3 and then
after this maybe a four so suddenly even
long casting is not safe anymore
because you know it was to play a 5 then
94 b5 that might come to the 6 so here I
made another brave decision after rook
AC 1
and you know I just asked myself what's
my worst piece and okay let's forget
about the king for a moment he's
actually Perry is just yeah McCain is
okay so far surviving they're like my
worst piece is definitely the stroke on
a8 so I decided just to activate the
rock by playing a five and not nothing
much nothing much to do obviously why
does not want to damage the spawn
structure so White has played this move
b5 the idea is obviously for me to
exchange everything and so on and so on
okay so whites to move now so how should
we play next
yeah so I can either move my knight back
to c5 or I found this square pretty good
for for it's pretty good for the Queen
so played Queen to c5 now I cannot move
his Knight
because his knight has to stay here to
protect the bishop and yeah actually all
of these other pieces don't do much the
ropes now on the Queen and the night so
really why does not have much of a
choice here so after Queen c5 he was
happy
she just exchanged one pawn I took any
play Bishop to b3 attacking my knight I
have to go back now Knight extensity is
super dangerous right because of this
this pin I might be brave but not that
brave so night to b6 after Knight b6 I
do want still to play a for get some
more space so white had to play a for
himself okay well what to do next I was
really really trying to you know to
activate the sukhani 7 but very white
use prophylaxis himself so what to do
next
Bishop a6 and rook to d8 was suggested
what's the problem with that yeah the f5
Square might become pretty weak Knight
a5 I wonder if you can sacrifice
immediately also after Bishop a6 you can
try to play in Nigerian f1 so it might
not work immediately although maybe it
can Bishop f6 Knight g4 Bishop a fun
night of 6 check but Bishop by 6 I will
probably just play rook F 2 and rhudi 8
and then 94 95 so the bishop on the
ancien is actually doing a very good job
on defending those two squares d7 b a--
and then ov8 and low castle okay that
that's possible the problem with this is
know what's the weakness of a long
castle
in the future yes but actually this King
here on the 8th is defending this pawn
of seven so even if I give you one and
two moves he's not taking me on of seven
yeah so I'm also pretty tied up he's
staying there forever
yeah it's quite strange right they may
change chess has changed so much in the
past 10 20 years especially but it's
about the king placement we always learn
when we are kids that we need to castle
castle defend the king but actually
computers has shown us much how can we
even play with the King on in the middle
of the board obviously this is a special
case I was pretty much forced to do so
but no so here again I was asking myself
what's my worst piece you know I have a
few pieces well not as active but then I
again I I looked at this truck on on a8
and I was thinking okay well can this
would be effective where is it go
exactly so it's other be eight or a
seven
so the here I had to make a choice and I
really preferred Luke a7 just to guard
all the seventh range just in case that
you would not sure why but you know just
maybe it's also a waiting move to see
what white is doing Luke a7 was played
rook to be won now was played by by
white and can't quite quick I can't
quite remember what was the idea but I
decided to play rook c7 maybe defend the
pollen c6 Queen f2 was played
and now wrote to d7 just making some
wedding moves although I think that he
wanted to jump on the night but I can't
remember right now
and maybe some some night at five with
some some checks my queen is aligned now
here so route d7 was played Bishop d1 so
now the idea is that this knife here on
B C's feels a little bit uncomfortable
now with the rookies here and the queen
is here so Bishop d1 afraid and I played
Bishop a6
now if the rook moves then I have this
one you've already shot d3 and I take on
e4
so technically I will be defending at
five square but now why trade night to
f2 then I to f5 I'm sorry Queen takes f2
I have to exchange the Queen's otherwise
I'll lose the the night here and rook
takes F to okay
black to move let's see who can find the
best move for black here that's you
folks pretty good yeah
so if 94 I think white has a Bishop h5
if I'm not mistaken and if you play rook
g5 I have rook b8 check rogue d8 and
Bishop takes f7 you have to take the
bishop and all takes d8
to sector the rope okay rook takes and
then taking on a four that is
interesting but I think that he can play
maybe look a one then take on a five
also ninety six is coming so actually
this the in this case it's actually not
a threat for him to take on dead and
iPhone v6 exactly so we're here with
once we exchange the Queen's
another step you know in a post process
of thinking what stage of the game are
we
we're in the middle game endgame or
opening we have to think about different
things now in a usually in the in uh
when we have the middle game we want to
ask us of what's a worst piece so how
can we develop the pieces in this case
because we are in an endgame is pretty
much the same principle would one minor
change we just have to add the King into
the equation right because we know that
in any of the King is a very strong
piece
so King d8 was played now what's the
idea well pretty simple I okay I come
out of those checks with the night the
Kings will come to c7 and you know I'm
just gonna be a pawn up right so so why
not
okay well the only question is left to
answer what to do after Bishop to h5
because now my rook is attacked and my
net is getting attacked so this is what
happened in the game so Bishop to h5
what to do here g5 and if I take the
knight of this I can take metaphysics
actually wait can I take note takes an
h5 though looks a little bit awkward
there so I'll play g4 attack attack the
rook and no mate anymore Knight takes e4
and if I take the rook
knight Knight takes some age six maybe
you're getting close you're getting
killed you're almost there they're
probably there is some compensation
there so what is all those witnesses
here here and here so what I've played I
took on a four white well whitening suit
so now by the way the King on DA
prevented all those checkmates rugby
eight is not no longer is so effective
Bishop takes g6 now wait a second before
taking the bishop I can also take on c3
so obviously between saving the bishop
on on g6 and 7d rockin on b1 which is
defending from the from the mate white
chose to save the rook any play the roxy
one okay again I can take the bishop
what wait a second 94 I can also take
this one yeah yeah so Kevin it moves we
first we look we look for checks
captures and threats oh there were no
checks and in that position so first of
all we we look for captures captures now
obviously after exegesis is also
captured but we have to figure this out
so 9 X t4 he played rook a to because
rook yeah it was impossible here the
bishop and now finally I take the bishop
on g6 roof takes a five I'm pretty sure
he did not want to take this spot on h6
probably week a week upon Rho takes a
five was attacking my my bishop but now
G takes f five rook takes on a six and
simply c5 okay so we get to this end
game where I have a knight and how many
pawns I have to count not three pawns
there one two three and usually such
such and games are supposed to be one
let me just show you what happened just
a few more moves another show
till the end c5 g3 was played so I'm
just I want to improve my king
first of all put my king on the e7 roof
to see to the the worst thing here for
white is that really white has no plan
there's no I mean it looks like work has
some weaknesses but this knife only four
is it some well defended and just
defending everything that I can do
whatever I want
so folks it was play king f7 I decided
to move my king over this side I can
also try to bring it to the center I did
want to keep one of the rooks on the
board because just to have some check
threats
kingi to king g6 rook AAA it was played
rugby for trying to put to play c4 rook
c8 was played h5 ruiji it just oh no
probably many options how to win this
endgame rook c8 group DT okay - and now
I decided to play f4 G takes a 4 e takes
a four rook to e8 I got f3 any any move
with the king backwards will be will be
made so he has to play king h3 and ok
what is White's what is blacks best move
here in this position now I did not find
a move that makes me feel any better
but I found the second best I guess what
is the best move in the position so I
played in a game I played f2 check
that's not the best more let's see if
you guys can beat me to it
rook d1 and if I take if I take the
knight
if to is what I favorite game it's also
pretty good I think
yeah not not not 96 so the problems
that's where I play the f to allow the
skin to go back to g2 and mine might not
had to get stuck here
f5 it's probably uh it looks like almost
everything is winning here but the best
move is rook to e3
right so putting the rope here and now
Knight to g5 and I think that the only
way that white can defend from it is
King H for now I thought that i have h
f2 but if f2 then he can take with the
rook if i'm not mistaken but i think
that the idea here is I can bring my
king now and his king is cut off he
cannot come back
so king g6 maybe start pushing all those
pawns as well so this was this was the
best the best move that I could have
played I have to check immediately King
G to route d1 and I saw that I get the
exchange because now I'm typing f1 and
yeah he took took took update c4 and
eventually I want this game you know two
healthy pawns up especially with time
pressure so the the way that the reason
why I wanted to show you this is
recently we really see if we go back to
to the Edit opening we see lots of those
moves like rook g8 this is this was a
move and also always think about your
opponent's plan how how can you prevent
this what is what's your worst piece
what's what's my candidate moves it's
very very important for us to fix the
process of thinking and they're not
because just you know as I said this was
a population and what what what is they
curious to see is that if you
so the interview with Vladimir Kramnik
he prepared rook g8 two years ago it was
actually for a different tournament
different mesh he wasn't even supposed
to play it right now
but you know that's that's that's the
importance of the population that's how
hard work pays off in the end
thank you and good luck to you guys
[Music]